a new report on the school massacre in
uvalde texas confirms police could have
stopped it before 19 children and two
teachers were killed an active shooter
training center run by texas state
university points to multiple occasions
when officers had a chance to target the
gunman at robb elementary school janet
chamleon has reaction to the new report
stunning new information details missed
opportunities uvalde police had in
preventing the robb elementary massacre
an officer armed with a rifle had the
gunman in sight as the shooter
approached the school building but
didn't fire instead the report indicates
the officer asked his supervisor for
permission to shoot the suspect the
supervisor either did not hear or
responded too late the use of force
decisions always rest with the officer
who is going to use the force there was
no requirement for that officer to ask
for permission to shoot the report
highlights another missed chance the
first officer arriving on the scene
might have seen the gunman to prevent
him from entering the building if he
hadn't been driving so fast or instead
approached on foot
and the report concludes what many have
believed that based on current evidence
it is possible that some of the people
who died could have been saved if they
had received more rapid medical care we
believe there should have been an entry
at that as soon as you can the new
information follows last week's
emotional city council meeting this was
not
not supposed to happen you failed
because you are not taking care of the
city they are 19
children
massacre a texas legislative committee
is also investigating and is expected to
release its report soon for cbs mornings
janet chamleon houston